what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and my
announcement is that i got invited to
the spider-man no way home world
premiere that is taking place tomorrow
so i'm really really excited about it
super excited that i'm gonna be able to
see the movie tomorrow my reaction about
the film can post immediately after i
see the movie so i'm gonna post that and
no spoilers whatsoever will be talked
about in that reaction and for those of
you that have been asking me that have
found out that i'm going to the premiere
no i'm not going to be posting any
spoilers and any videos
i'm not going to put spoilers in a
thumbnail not going to put spoilers in
any of the video titles so you don't
have to worry about getting anything
spoiled from me and when the video comes
out where i do talk about the movie i
will state in the very beginning i am
going to talk about spoilers for
spider-man no way home i'm not trying to
ruin it for anybody it's going to be the
biggest movie
possibly of all time and i don't want to
ruin that for anybody i'm kind of
staying away from everything right now
all the leaks right now i'm not even
really watching some of the clips right
now because it's tomorrow for me
and we've waited such a long time for
this and i've talked about this for over
a year and it's a it's kind of surreal
that it's tomorrow like
it's kind of not hitting me and for you
know the entire world it's it's next
week it's it's really this week because
it's sunday now so i mean only a few
more days to go for the world basically
and look out for my reaction tomorrow
it's going to be pretty late um because
it starts at 7 30 pacific time so i'm
gonna go ahead and say it's going to
come out maybe around 10
11 o'clock pacific time so pretty late
especially if you're on the east coast
or in the uk or wherever you're from
but probably expect around 10 11 and
from then i will you know i'll do
whenever i'm allowed to when the embargo
lives because i obviously promise sony
that i'm not going to talk about
anything obviously right so whenever i
can i will but don't worry i will say
spoilers and and the final thing i want
to say is thank you to everybody for the
support that you've given me over time
because i'm only going to this because
of all the support that you all have
given me over time this is all because
of you and i just want to say thank you
i love you all 3 000 and look out for my
reaction tomorrow for spiderman no way
home almost forgot to say it but woof